think of my world you and I think that
in itself sounds quite grand but I think
that if I were to say anything about the
way that I see the wall I think that one
of the most important elements to
remember is cultural sensitivity that
when we deal with when we have
relationships with other people in other
parts of the world I think that we can
never assume that what we think we're
communicating is in fact how they see it
but I think it that's what I've learned
from living in different places around
the world and also being of I guess by
cultural being bicultural I think that
that's the one thing that has influenced
all of the work that I do I think that
one of the one of the interesting things
about working with people who are based
across the world is the way that you
have to modify either your behavior or
the way that you communicate to suit
that local environment and I think that
especially in Asia where people are
often coming from a totally different
cultural background with totally
different expectations of how you might
behave I think that that's both one of
the challenges of what what we do but
also one of the wonderful kind of
abilities to engage with others while
there might not be one specific instance
I would say that it's more about
learning how to kind of fun how to fit
in a different
you